he was 15 years old my wife and I went
out of town my parents his grandparents
came to stay with him for the weekend a
month later there was 200 worth of porn
charges on my DirecTV bill
that he blamed on my parents his
grandparents
this is true he said that they ordered
anal party three
we're innocent yes so thank you for
saying that I don't even know how much
200 dollars
what he gets for it is to order this is
the type of [__] he is
like I'll be there too my dad did not
order anybody
there's two people in my relationship
like if it's not one in line with the
other one night we were in San Antonio
and somebody asked this question who
ordered the porn
it's a good question he we're arguing or
whatever and he was sitting on the side
stage and he goes hey can I say
something
they both sound like this to me
[Music]
he goes hey can I say something
and I go yeah
there is actually something that I need
to get off of my chest and I feel like
this is the most appropriate time to be
able to do that you guys just got done
talking about the whole uh porn thing
shut the [__] up bro
[Applause]
I was gonna say we've been I wouldn't
say arguing I'd say more debating for 10
years for a Whole Decade about who had
ordered this and now let me start it off
with this for those of you who did not
believe me
eat it
um Jacob had been out of the house
grandma grandpa had been out of the
house
[Music]
jerk off
it was a Revenge Club
what do you did you guys know I mean
okay you may know you may know this you
may not know this
back at that time
on his Wikipedia page there was only one
child listening
yeah
one child Little Jacob who wasn't on the
Wikipedia page
let's play another one who started his
[__] career
tonight
he had ordered the porn
because
Jacob kept taking him off with the
Wikipedia page so he he did that anybody
and I mean anybody can make changes to
any Wikipedia page there is that is so
[__] stupid
guys my age go on there for information
oh my God palm tree has six sticks like
I had no idea these [__] guys are in
there like
by the way this dude look man you know
when your kids lie
they all have certain tells I know you
think you get away with it your parents
know when you're lying because whenever
he lied about a second after the LIE he
would do the oh
it's unfortunately true I went into the
room I go hey man you have any idea why
the Wikipedia page says you're the only
kid and he goes no
oh
I mean I had my reasons Trevor her for
the first 10 years of my life kept
telling me I was adopted that was really
funny though it wasn't that funny he was
like hey no one's that tall in this
family you should get tested and I was
like for what
I was like this right now this is the
perfect golden number 27. nobody's home
James already been caught looking in the
morning
opportunities
I'm an adult at this time I'm 20 years
old so I I don't know about itemized
bills I
live out of the house yeah
but I have to pay them and I know so I
know by ordering the porn off DirecTV
that's going to show up on the bill and
he's looking at it uh
what happened
[Music]
right now I'm so glad you weren't or
else I would have never had that joke
all worth it yeah I had my favorite
edits that you made yeah I had a couple
I had a really my favorite one though my
favorite one was Josh Wolf has five kids
and these are their names
jacob jacob jacob Jacob and Jacob right
but all of them were spelled differently
so there was like a p before the J one
was just with like a k and a u one had
like an oon clot above the O I would
like very like Swedish or Norwegian I
was like oh yeah I love that Jacob that
was a great one you wrote
Josh Wolf has three kids none of them
are named Trevor
you guys now his page is completely
locked you can't make any more changes
to it and I stuck with it saying he has
three thousand children
do you know what else one of you wrote
in there which made me laugh in the bio
part it said Josh Wolf started comedy
when he was 14 and left home like Mowgli
from The Jungle Book
it really made me laugh I was bummed
when whoever erased that I'm like that
should have stayed that was the best one
I like to smoke weed
I like to smoke weed bring it
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]